Just now it’s too thin.
Just now.
You know, tomorrow it’s going to be thick
again.
It has to do with the climate also in the
Museum
because if the water disappears every night,
it can be one or two buckets the next day.
What do you think?
Yeah, we’ve got it.
And then we can let it stay for awhile.
Let it rest for ten minutes and see what’s
happened.
And then we can stir it up again with high
speeds like vrrrrrooommm…
The level should be tomorrow up to seven inches.
Then we are done.
That’s what we need.
It’s thickening up already.
I’m afraid if we add more mud then on Monday when I come in
it’s going to be a solid block.
And you won’t be here to help me!
And I’ll cry.
See?
Look at this clump!
You see it?
Should we keep putting water in?
Ja.
I thought this would take four days, but it’s
taken five days.
When they asked me when I wanted to go home,
I said I can go home Friday
but I was lucky someone told me that no, you have
to go Saturday because you have to be at the
airport so early
so you wouldn’t be able to work on anything
on Friday.